welcome back to las vegas now smg media
group the sponsors of this next segment
is introducing us to a software that
helps simplify the insurance process
that can get very complicated i spoke
with creator robert ritter to learn more
check it out
you started a company called endsmark
and it's all about fintech software in
the insurance industry so tell us about
what enzmark does
okay i started ends mark in november
1983
after years and years and years in the
insurance business as both a life
insurance agent and a general agent um
mostly with mass mutual
um
i was always disappointed
with the presentations of the industry
they're like 40 pages of a compliance
document
boring as can be
and i wanted to create a system that
explained the product
simply
and accurately
on top of that big 40 page proposal so
we develop what the industry calls diet
proposals
with a minimum number of pages
explaining the idea and the ideas are
all over the place
but that's the essential reason they
formed the company to create the
software to design that kind of
illustration
wow thank you because it can get very
wordy and dull and hard to understand so
who is your target audience robert
there's three
life insurance companies
uh we started doing business with them
and have done business with over 100 of
them including the biggest ones some of
the biggest ones anyway
also
individual
sales people out in the field we have a
retail division
but we also have a wholesale division to
deal with what are called independent
marketing organizations
which are
organizations
that have been formed to help individual
producers with their production and do
you offer retirement planning services
as well with endsmart we've got a
product called wealthy and wise which is
unique in the
industry that measures a client's need
for cash flow in retirement against the
assets available
to create it
it's amazing on how you access assets
if you have individuals say with seven
different asset classifications
there are 5 000 different combinations
that you can draw the money from those
wow and if you're doing it for 40 years
that's another however many that is
tens of thousands
you can't do it on an excel spreadsheet
our program does it in about 30 seconds
and it tells each client
to take his retirement goals from the
following assets at the following times
so he ends up with better net worth than
if you just did it sloppily how can
people contact insmart contact you and
your team if they have any questions or
are interested in using your product
the easiest way is to go to our website
which is www.www.insmart.com
or go to my blog page i've got 220 blogs
i've written on what we do
he knows what he's talking about thank
you to smg media group for sponsoring
that segment for more information just
visit endsmark.com
we'll be right back right here on las
vegas now